an escape now for New York that is the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now during election season failing
political leaders put a lot of time and
energy into changing public perception
believing that better PR is the answer
they feverishly attempt a brand reboot
now Biden's done it more times than I
can say mega Maga but it's maddening to
see elected officials try this in the
city that never sleeps or maybe we
should call it the city that's never
safe
ask me why does New York lead the entire
nation in population loss because their
wallets their safety their freedom and
their quality of their kids education
are under attack so they're hitting
their breaking point they're looking in
other states like the Carolinas
Tennessee Texas Florida and elsewhere
and they feel like their money will go
further they'll feel safer and they'll
live life Freer like I said sound bites
not sound policy that's absurd
y that's pathetic and New York mayor
Eric Adams wants you to forget about his
City's high taxes and high crime problem
and think all that he is doing is really
good and so he does stuff like now use a
hashtag that says get stuff done on
social media now look at Eric with mayor
Pete yesterday
well yeah he's getting stuff done but
here's the stuff that's actually getting
done Subway crime is up 41 in New York
this year and Transit murders at around
a 25-year high but mayor Adams says that
everyone needs to realize it's only six
felony crimes a day in the subway
if you do an analysis of the six major
cities in America the crime waves is
tackling all of our cities New York City
is the safest also showed how I have
turned around the morale of a police
department yes we have a real crime
problem that we're addressing but part
of that is the perception that every day
those six crimes are being highlighted
over and over again
the man is totally tone deaf does he not
understand anyone especially women
commuting by Subway are terrified at the
prospect of being the next victim
and what does he want the press to do
conceal the surveillance videos
well at least they've made some arrests
in the subway attacks not so in Upstate
New York where that Compass care that
pro-life Center that was firebombed on
June 7th in a so-called Jane's Revenge
attack there was four hundred thousand
dollars worth of damage done to that
charitable organization but it's not a
priority is it not for New York's AG
because she's too busy Leticia James
carrying out her own Revenge attack on
Donald Trump
but the least shocking development in
New York politics lately was the New
York slimes editorial endorsing Governor
Kathy hokel now over and over again they
write zeldon Lee zeldin has demonstrated
a loyalty to trumpism over his oath to
defend American democracy in the
constitution in his campaign for
governor he makes a spurious spurious
arguments about crime and Advocates
returning to the zero tolerance policies
that have no Clear Connection to
improving Public Safety
well I hate to break it to the gray old
lady but that that's called getting
tough on crime kids and that's exactly
what needs to be done in New York
that was only when the polls started
getting shaky for hokel did she even
want to talk about re-examining things
like bail reform
but that didn't last long
she still hasn't talked about locking up
anyone committing any crimes okay anyone
who commits a crime under our laws
especially with the change he made to
bail has consequences I don't know why
that's so important
now if that sentence didn't lose her the
election I I don't know what will
she just doesn't care about you if
you're living in New York and she's
making it clear
there was very few people in Congress
who have a more pro-life record someone
who said he'd bring on a pro-life Health
commissioner you know how much power
that person has over of her decisions on
regulations they could little use their
power to shut down clinics so that is a
frightening spectacle women need to know
that that's on the ballot this November
as well
and to think that this was once the
party of JFK
meanwhile the left claims that hokel is
a leader who is focused on finding
solutions to the big problems rather
than getting off track with partisan
Warfare
oh really they think she's not partisan
oh okay
we're here to save
that the era of trump and zeldin and
Molinaro just jump on a bus and head
down to Florida where you belong okay
get out of town get out of town
because you don't re you don't represent
our values
you are not New Yorkers you're not New
Yorkers although in typical weasel
fashion she then tried to clarify those
nasty remarks
New York's 2.84 million Republicans
heard her though loud and clear she was
saying telling him to get out
the fact is hokel is now and always has
been a radical Harpy who just like mayor
Adams shows more concern for migrants
flooding the state than for the nearly
20 million Americans who still call New
York their home
but don't worry because hoko says she
has no plans to raise taxes right now
New Yorkers I should hope not raise
taxes in an economic downturn
and look where New York ranks in the
just released business tax climate index
number 49.
so the angles message to the good people
of New York tonight is the same as it is
to the good people of Connecticut
Michigan Illinois
Etc
tired of this yet
two weeks from tonight the voters in
Liberal strongholds like New York have a
chance to save themselves and send a
powerful message to the Democrat Party
to quote president Trump in 2016 what do
you have to lose
you don't have to escape the state
just choose to escape its bad leadership
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else